but I tried to make on time I'm from
Universal cago I'm a booth booth
business school professor of Finance so
the talk I'm giving is very much like
economics finance taste but the glad
that it's a it's a great you know
scheduling in the sense that the this
paper could we think about the natural
extension of the first talk that you see
from the mining mining and what about
whatever miners are risk averse and what
if they form force and what would be the
evolution of the you know structure of
the industry it's also related to the
second paper which is on this waste of a
resources etc we would like to link the
formation of poor to the excessive use
of the energy etc so these are these two
things that are you know putting
together so anyway so I I didn't at the
justified slides that much so so these
slides is just not like I think for this
audience I don't need to talk more I
would like to talk about a little bit
about about the disproof work on this
weed called arms race
I think arms races will be there in any
zero-sum game it's basically the you
know as long as you're imposing weekly
increasing over your reward function as
well as that it's always budget
balancing then you have this issue where
it's a total for everybody if they do a
little bit gonna get a little bit more
but obviously because it's a project but
you're balanced so you obviously Jitsu
stealing someone from other and this is
the create so there's a competition
where in a way that if we is from an
economists perspective that you you
potentially will lead a lot of
inefficiency
so I'm not so this is a second slide
that you're basically saying that in
reality even though that what we know
it's decentralized a lot of you know
people would like to keep individual
miners so nobody can dominate the
network however that in reality is
always a mining pose oh it's not always
it's just there nowadays it is it
completely dominates the solo mining so
I gotta have a two-inch you know - from
my perspective a very quite interesting
pictures for you one is this mining war
during the PCH for King I happen to know
one of the the Pittman's top guy so it
give me some data on that thing and then
the mining for evolution you probably
already seeing that it just basically
telling you that this industry
everything is about a big guys to become
a kind of Allah burger play of Monopoly
that table I will explain to you that
what do you mean by oligopoly monopoly
and there's a concerns over
sustainability and all these things okay
what we are trying to do in this paper
is a from economists perspective where
the miners not only can just join in one
pool but also can joining a lot of
applause which seems like it in
practices they are doing now to clarify
certain fallacies on whether you're
gonna have one big pool or not the
answer is no so you're gonna see that
why this again is related to this
coalition proof logic that behind the
analysis is you're seeing in the first
paper and then highlighted one important
a mechanism to linking the pores and the
rising mining power which now people
seems to agree that this is a pretty
excessive all right so this is one thing
oh you don't see the top how do I can
how can I just make it a smaller so that
at the top title showed up
close it maybe this is a fan already
control all right this is a pciture PCH
a hard-working late on an 18 so in
viewing this space you know that it is a
announces it and here is the folk starts
and then all of a sudden death this is a
hushed power total hash power between
these two and then you have this thing
and and and it when I thought about all
the things are saying oh this is like
very interesting kind of like a fighting
war without any I guess general or their
things but actually not so this is the
composition of the war hash power war of
these pores of the mining powers
associated to each team so bases like it
two armies working I know you have
different squads and if these squads are
just the set of lines of each other and
the fighting over each other so though
these are the manuals and obviously you
know the I'm not trying to tell you too
much about how for cosecha but I want to
tell you that the D as economist to
think of incentives and how do you
coordinate all these things is just
complete changed when you think about it
it's like individual guys peasants for
versus you know very very disciplined
soldiers right so so these are the
things that this is a just telling you
the illusion of the coal mining of the
post each each color represents one poor
so you already seeing this type of thing
and then you see that the the rise also
rises over hash power the red line is a
hash power over time and we like to you
know link these these two with a purely
purely economic
economist it's a type of a model and
then we want to see that a wider force
seems grow first and it is slow
it's not like someone is taking taking
it
okay so preview of our results is that
we know that if you have a risk aversion
that's exactly the first paper was
talking about is that you have you're
very risk-averse it seems like it you
wanted for because you know we would
like to diversify so the indeed that the
pooling implies the significant risk
sharing benefits and the first order
thing is saying that okay once you
diversify then actually you worsens to
the arms race so remember that
underlying is based basically people
killing each other in my perspective if
you think about it like if killing each
other as a as a proof-of-work maintain
the stability that's totally fat in in
this model there's no network stability
thing it's just just people engaging in
the hash power war etc then with the
idea of allowing them to participate in
the pores that basically improve the
individual payoff a better herder
everybody else okay so that's the and we
want to show it's a quantitative okay so
therefore this can I could link to the
egregious at the energy user with the
pause and basically there once you have
a four that initially if there's no poor
then when I do it I might not do it just
because you know it's an individual
minor there's a lot of a risk of going
on you know given that a potentially the
price of bitcoins bail but alternatively
I bethought alternately you could have
put it into the force then a lot of
people just getting the second point is
as a risk aversion implies pores but it
doesn't imply pause to merger or
centralization so that's the point that
probably you know I when I read all
these are literature was not emphasize
that much but okay slowly that I see
people start to discuss are not the
reason the - can join multiple force and
they can't diversify themselves and you
can see this logic very clearly when you
write down the write down the model so
this is the links to the very very old
economics in the finance and of a
logical which is the following is that
no all these investors like you add to
everybody you think about your investors
by purchasing some stocks buy some
stocks etc right you are risk averse
that's why we need put into the funds
etc but you never you should have not
asked saying no because I'm a risk
averse to say
so therefore Google should emerge you
with a Facebook right or Facebook is not
a good example because these two things
it seems like it's a it's a moving
together let's think about it someone
else neither you could have provided
good hedge we never should do that
because if you are the risk averse
investor you just put half the money
into the into the Facebook have the
money into the someone else's also that
a you know you diversify by yourself you
don't need to merge these two company
together to today they diversified for
you okay
so that's basically the idea that you
know - in here is like English then we
builded equilibria model mining industry
and then you will see that how do we my
name close I will basically just skip
this this slide is just because
everything here is it should be very
obvious is that you know they repeatedly
competed to record transactions then
they get to this coin base and then you
have a tool to naman oh there's another
thing that it's very important from the
economists perspective is that a day
they will find a way to resolve this
tomorrow has a the issue that you know
explain to you basically using the
partial solution okay and here the
difficulty of adjustment is exactly the
source of so-called arms race the it's
basically saying you if you have a lot
of a lot of people get seen the
difficulty Canada just initially if
you're only several people that you put
in okay everybody is happy but then
other people come in the very first
moment that the other people come you
make make everybody else a harder so
that's that's the so-called arms race in
terms of like it this is the kind of
like the the military war it's this is
the base to basically the analogy that
we
okay so let me just just telling you the
details of the the setting we are
working on so we have the let's say your
solo mining okay and we are in the
anyway I will put a risk aversion
version there so solution the persona
that arrives with rate proportional to
the share of gas hash rates so we assume
it's the proportional war and - pay off
look like this
EXO low because be so low times are -
the clm not 80 so this is a think about
it just one period model this is the
only just static model okay then then we
have this standard way of modeling the
payoff function the outcome here big
lambda is global hash weights in the end
we will endogenous global hash rates
it's just you know a lot of people are
coming in like okay and you have these
constants it's not a really big
important thing the R is dollar reward
everything is then here is the cost of
operation electricity of the linear in
the hash rates that are that we're
consider okay and then what's the poor
okay a proportional mining for so here
we we I will explain to you that I
Indiana why I why we focus on the
proportional mining poor instead of this
GPS thing okay a proportional mining
poor is basically combines everybody's
hash weights together to solve one
puzzle and it attributed their rewarding
proportion to the hash rates
contributors and here is basically this
partial solution that initially we were
discussing about the data you could use
the partial solution to approximate this
hash contributions to a to economists
typically you will say that this is
usually it's hard it's like you know
you're working working working and in
the end you just surveyed ego workers
how much harder you're working and
everybody just inflates right you being
are a you know a lot of times you you
just like to a little bit of inflation
over the working hour etcetera but in
this environment we know we know we have
the solution of the of the hazards so
then then if you joining a pool what you
get is that this is the pool bigger
lambda bigger lambda typically just
denote the whatever the big four
existing big pores hash rates and what
you get is is basically lambda a divided
by the whole thing
because after your joining this add up
and then the poor gonna generated apart
this part over in the water and you have
are they all so you just - your
contribution and here the poor becomes
poor the the chance of the poor together
the reward becomes one over
and you can show that because the risk
aversion
then those EXO lo had explored the
expectation is identical whether the
distribution is the second order the
castle they dominated therefore that I
would like to joining a poor to smooth
out stuff okay so so far that it's just
saying that you know as a risk-averse
individual agents in this world they
should have participating a poor to
self-insure and here is the slides
telling you that to tell you that the
minor the the the king from
participating a poor versus not to
participate a poor first first of all
that if I'm joining a bigger poor the
king will be bigger that this slides is
trying to show the second a point I want
to deliver is that it even if I joining
a light like a pretty small for the game
the first thing you do get turning there
will be very very big which is like a
twenty plus twenty percent of the pool
of the post twenty percent boost
measuring in terms of the certainty
equivalent okay
however this doesn't mean that you know
one caveat as the core logic of the
behind this leg whether we should have
see a big poor or not just because due
to the risk aversion reason is that a
miners are decided how to locate a cross
post not whether or not joining the poor
okay so this is justice saying that they
would like to put joining the poor's it
doesn't mean that they always put all
the eggs into one basket okay
so I will spend some time to talk to you
about the fee contract structure and for
the audience like this that I can talk a
little bit more although that I'm not
really the expert on you know the way
that exactly design on this like the
first enroll or they didn't do things
but let me just just give you that what
I what we find so there's a poor manager
okay the he is coordinating all these
hot hash rates and then basically
charging port fees so this is the one
thing that a you know in a way that
actually interested me it's it's it's a
business okay it's a business it's not
like it's something that if people
putting together and a play with their
it's a business the the poor fee is it
could it be very substantial okay and
the contracting variable of all the
workers who come in you think about a
lift over right think about that it's
basically that you get your reward based
on your partial solutions and then hash
partial solution block is below a lowest
I show that then the true solution so I
believe that everybody you know let's
say that I mean the in the in the true
solution you need to hit setting the
zeros but in counting your partial
solution so you only need to hitting
let's say 12 zeros which is you know
during the finding the finding the true
solution
it's you've got to collect a lot of a
lot lot of a partial solution which
represents that you're working all right
so this is already you're seeing it in
in the first talk and here is basically
saying that if I can use these partial
solutions to allocate the rewards okay
so there are three kinds of the of the
compensation contracts the first one is
a ten slightly different country in
three categories the first one is a
proportional and that's what we are
emphasizing on what we were were working
on and here is basically that are you
what you get as the participants get is
basically the same thing lambda a over
lambda a plus then a B you know you see
already seen without a war minus F but
now because you are participating on
your acknowledge the manager is helping
you therefore that you are paying this
your you only get a womanís F the the
management to get F a little bit okay so
with P tilde this is a basically scrag
output the wage that you work there we
collectively produces something then we
share the second one is a PPS and that's
the kind of like hourly base to wage
which means that you just you know
this is a related to the deterministic
payoff that initially that the first
paper was talking about here is
basically you work there independent of
the outcome just to show you that it
this is the hours that I'm working ended
up there's a also clouded my mining
seems like it's it was journey opposite
of the PPS which means that the guy who
is individual mind I would really really
like to get some some some some
computation power instead of if he's
renting out he's basically boring okay
he's just trying to gather that and pay
the other side as a machine provider
some money for them so that's this table
we focus on proportion approach just
because it's it's like prevalent and
also that in here is is relevant for the
risk versions or do you think so in the
future in the potential extension that I
saw that I remember that at the some of
the comments in the first paper was
saying oh what if you have different
risk versions the world were gonna play
out and those things will will be
suitable to study in the suffering
worker with with with slightly different
contracts of the proportion of pros so
what we do is basically that assuming
proportionate pause and assuming every
agents in this economy are all have the
same risk aversion similar so including
the managers okay including managers
otherwise you think about if manager are
risk aversion that's why it's basically
basing my comments to the first talk on
theme which is that if the managers are
risk averse yes then it's optimal for
him to just you know rent out give the
workers as a deterministic and he bear
all the risk
it's basically that's the point and now
he here in this framework because the
managers have the same risk aversion so
they also would like to equalize the
risk this is the data and basically
behind what we tried to show first of
all first colin is on the total hash
rates you don't it's rising number of
course total now is a forty three top
five percent so that just is showing you
that how concentrated they are top five
percent is a pick
the top-5 calculated their summer of a
hash power divided by the total is about
62 now a 2017 used the highest is a 75
there's an average of fee that the
managers are charging so every block are
coming out the manager going to charge
that part of the fee you it's very
overtime a little bit but it's a while I
get to two percentage percent and here's
a fraction or proportional one paper
what one thing that a typically you know
economists write papers who will say you
know I would like to explain the world
some particular patan some particular
pattern one pattern we would like to
explain or kind of like it telling you
that you know this is a true in the
world and I can't generate it this is
the fact that the top five guys are
charging little bit higher fee the
bigger fonts bigger bigger posts are
charging a slightly higher fee or you
know it's a two percent of us at one
point - this is the top five pours this
is all post and that that is the thing
that we would like to would like to
deliver here is a current contract
sample and then then here is basically
that we were in the in the in the first
target towards the end about it is why
the mining force would like to cheat by
hiding the observe discovered of a true
solution a little bit it's basically
reflected all all these like a little
bit of fancy of deep something but at
given time that I will not all right so
here's a really the given though these
are preparation then we would like to
set up the model okay so model gonna be
very simple as I said you have the risk
new risk averse agents okay so that the
risk participating then poor become a
real concern the second is that you have
a lot of active miners who are trying to
find at home to go to the go to the
forced to work okay and the day they
they will acquire hash rate lambda a and
here we assuming Selenia its will be
very easy
to add a fixed cost what's important is
that the impor managers will set the FM
to compete so in this in this
environment is basically all them active
met at active miners they could buy
certain hash power they facing a bunch
of the poor managers offering that
service and then they could go there to
mine and obviously they get a reward
because it's the contractor they get
back so we're gonna analyze in the
baseline first they'll just take these
as assumption and then add on a little
bit of restriction which which which
helps you to clarify a lot of things so
we were first to analyze this and then
saying that okay let's add on a little
bit of a friction which means the
following in friction friction in the in
the economics typically means that
there's some firms that had a little bit
of the difference among these opposed
among relative to the other firm okay so
for M we said it's a poor endowed with
some passive hash rates which means that
these hash rates will not move or you
think about it it's like themselves etc
you think a lawyer offense before
proprietary hash power etc or did the
these things and those a little bit over
the endowment is related to this
so-called a monopolistic competition
which which means is the very very easy
way to explain it it's just you know I'm
offering the hand back there's a some
handbag the car the Gucci it's a really
high level I have a other handbag let's
say a little bit of coach you know the
pillow and all those legs hamburger
which has no bad name
okay and a different people will coming
to differ in the market right but but if
the coach you know some of the handbag
prices a little low even on the margin
attract the customer a little bit here
is basically the same thing that we have
a different force because of the owners
probably have a lot of the money
initially let's say the bitman guy and
he had this manufacturers and
is able to attract a lot of risk-averse
- to come in to join me that pool okay
and that is that is in a sense that it's
you know given that other active miners
are participating in that the other
active miners also would like to
participating because of the risk
aversion effect and those those things
are the key thing that we would like to
analyze all right so what's the active
miners problem that this is what what
basically that this paper is the thought
is we have the utility function of the
whole thing that if you'd a
participating of the lambda M which is
the contribution of their acquired hash
rates to pour em okay they buy the whole
thing at a linear cost so they just paid
- C thing and then obviously each poor
they calculated the sum of these rewards
and there you have those things they're
taking the total total Poor's hash rates
as a Karen okay I know you can show that
okay just just you know because it's
exponential there's a nice property of
this Poisson distribution etc you're
basically getting this problem you don't
need to remember those those things if
we needed at a risk aversion obviously
otherwise it's to say everything become
you know reduced to the risk that's not
what's also more important in the end we
have to close close the model because
there's a global hash rates lambda is
equals to many many pores together
putting together
Wow
yeah this is the so so there's a there's
a way to light because short answer is
this thing is is a deterministic right
it is you know this utility is over the
over the money right this is a money
it's a measuring money right and then
here from here to here I'm already
transformed into something called a
certainty equivalent is that it
initially people this is in terms of
money as well this inside is until in
terms of money and when you put a
utility there right so and and that's
the that's the active Robin what's poor
managers product okay poor managers poor
managers are are facing a little bit
more sophisticated problem is that what
they have to do is to know that the
other guys competitive with the bandage
etcetera and also that it take as given
that how much the fees that the other
firms are charging think about it be
basically you know different let's say
castling firms that are you on on the
road you know you're always seeing
different prices in different roles etc
they're pricing very strategically and
but what they have to do is so taking
others prices are given then they cannot
adjust that their price a little bit so
that made to me what we do and this
manager with em has this cash flow that
so then he has to has to has to maximize
the following okay so let me emphasize a
little bit that what what these things
are okay first of all the you should see
that there are three places that and FM
showed up okay and this is a very
important to understand what's going on
the first thing is the FM here this is
just basically capture the idea that if
I'm charging a little bit higher if i
fixing how many people participating
then my my written my benefit ago go up
and you just charge our price higher
place here this is the saying if I'm
charging a little bit higher price the
people coming in this is am is
active miner coming in is lower down
okay and then here is basically saying
that when you when I change this FM I
take it I took him to counter that when
I lower down the price or go or increase
the price the global hash rates is
changing because I'm a big enough firm
big enough for poor there's only like
let's say six top 70 top of 50 so so
they will take that into come this this
this this last part of the here isn't
really what the tribe is the main
results there that's saying that the
larger firms but so here's the main
results the larger firms will charge a
higher price because that not because of
their they're getting more etc you know
I will show you that it's so everything
is a proportional the reason they charge
a higher price is because they took into
account the fact that if they lower down
the price there's a more there's more
hash rates coming and they're hurting
themselves okay they understood that
this is the this is a zero-sum game
which is the arm spacer so they they
took in the count
therefore they increase the price to
deliberately shrinking the total hash
rate in this world
okay so here's a Calibri definition you
see that optimal fees Optima has rates
allocation market clearing and that's
that's and what we are linking back in
the end is that this papasa rates we
could think about is like how big is the
firm the funds initially has and then
they try to understand that what's the
implication on the different
distribution of the of the of the of the
pore size that in the next period of
growth alright so here is as a promise
that this is the a frictionless
benchmark which says that a you know
this is saying that is suppose take the
most plain vanila model like the first
first paper we see that you have a bunch
of people who who can participate in the
who can who can who can joining the pool
by themselves and try to figure out the
optimal way to do so okay the
proposition is follows they in this
world where there's no big pool managers
to start with right because in this
world there is no nobleman or other
people to charge all these fees or the
ability to set up and then F M equals 0
for M and then the or any allocation as
long as you make me make sure the total
size of different firms that adding up
to some number which is making sure that
nobody wants to get in further will be
this will be what would be the so here
is basically saying that the miners you
don't need to pour them together okay so
one one obvious way to show it is
basically one scenario you have a one
big fund you have a 10,000 people
everywhere but it gets in here you have
another situation spirit of the this guy
into to the same a thousand people just
put half here half here the the result
is I exactly identical there's a no no
no noise them
so that's the so the way we call the
fallacy was diversification for man
so interestingly you know I would like
to get some comments from I would like
to get some things saying you know seems
like this point is valid or you know
people realize it so this is an
interesting foreign post after we wrote
the paper off obviously initially we
didn't you know we were debating on
whether this results is interesting now
the mining in so this is a from a forum
post obviously this is a guy who is
actively mining okay multiple my mining
in multiple not only helps variants for
individual - but it is healthier for the
network in the current standard usage
there's a rich get richer the poor get a
poor tendency where large pores are more
attractive with that scroll even larger
so that's the lot of debate on that but
basically this guy is saying the other
you know if the miners actually think a
little bit of or that they could have
put it in two different ports then this
force is not there that's wrong I'm
saying this is the correct I'm saying
this is a correct and I'm saying that a
we we are basically pointing out the
same issue here and happily that
industry person we converge and a lot of
times you know that the finance industry
and academia just saw it's because the
opposite because industry person would
like to make money in the financial
market Wow academia tell them it doesn't
know it don't need to because there's no
money to make so this is why that I
would like to get some
ideally that if the guy who doesn't have
the mental cost of different things
which I think that at this point
probably that I know some people
locating two or three but it's not
everything obviously putting their their
hashed rates in every poor
that's exaggeration that I this is the
exactly exaggeration from the model what
we we know from the standard of Finance
textbook which is like back to 1970s
Jing Pharma Jing Pharma basically showed
that if you if you really think that
diversification is a very beneficial the
first twelve stocks is the most
important one after twelve it's like a
zero almost a zero game so here I don't
put any mental costs over allocating a
little bit more so therefore you should
diversify a hundred but technically you
should only like 12 but the twelve I
think it's already bigger than nowadays
it's like it well
okay okay so then I want to so I want to
tell you the dark side of a receiving or
mining force is basically saying that
you know have we have a mining race and
we'll keep what we can show is that if
there's an old mining poor than the
marginal benefit if it's a solo the the
total mining port lambda is only this
one but once you have a mining port to
allow them to diversify to a much
greater extent then the total mining has
power is way bigger is it because
they're you allow them to diversify to a
great extent let me just tell you this
is a we did some empirical results but
that's not a important I think this is a
very important concept that you know
this is the earth was one minute to talk
about is that this model if you would
see that is is like IO industry
organization where we look like we would
like to understand the evolution of the
mining industry and at the entry and
exit from the is is kind of an
interesting perspective to look at
through so what we hear is basically we
say we have mi incumbents and and there
they could pay some cost to acquire
these these are passionate rates and
enter compete with the rest of it
typical results will say okay as well as
long as you allow for let's say K equals
zero K equals zero which and when K
equals zero that means that the entrance
will not have a passive rates then
everything they're not gonna go what we
show proposition is that the income and
of course in our model has a very very
style as a fact about the finance
industry that income force will always
enjoy some market power the reason is
because the incumbent ports have a
little bit of initial magnets
whenever you in have initial magnets
which is this passive rates that they
can provide a better services to other
people it's like a Bank of America think
about a Wells Fargo etc
the fact that they already have a
certain base of the branchman Network
even though the new guys coming in they
cannot compete it with them on this so
this is just a showing you know that in
you know a mother there it's it's a it's
a free from the competition force
alright so here let me just wrap up so I
hope that this is the two things that I
want to deliver one is a risk aversion
implies pores
yes but the diversification across
forces will sustain decentralization and
I you know at some point I would like to
do some empirical work on that I just
try to see the if isn't indeed true that
from the same ip people across that
there's a this is a respects to the
blockchain sustainability and what we
also try to show is the fact that the
kind of real having pores that actually
could it generates some social batter
which is which is a you know there's a
lot of a lot of it you could be just
energy consumption due to the fact that
you could allow people to diversify are
doing bad things
[Applause]
take over so many questions yeah
my dear pressure but you mentioned there
was a estimates right yeah yes yes yeah
I think it's a practice a lot of lot of
practice score people however it's a
industry person that they also use the
same person same methodology would you
could you just do it order to do and
then you left right because to say your
kids in the hospital you have to stop
soon and then you know assume I don't
know there you just a semi there so
whatever your partial solution is there
you get a proportion of observations
yes yeah it's it's it's the same it's
the same if the contract is like it
tried to people coming in to understand
that a you know there's a summer
diversification effect which means that
exposed to I mean the we know but I have
to diversify everybody
stress the risk assumptions and how easy
is it to make break into like being more
the first result is is a very general
the first result is a very general in
the sense that you know whenever you
think so there are different forces of
why that we think to arrive rice right
one thing I think neha mentioned was
this is some little bit of the atom in
cost like you know except set up cost
set up cost which is we we we typically
interpret as a fixed cost if it's a
fixed cost then it's obviously it's much
better for just let one guy do it and
they let it do big because then the
average cost is that become very very
small so this is the standard of force
that we we're seeing in in many other
kind of context what I'm trying to
refute in this particular paper is that
it's not you know the the idea is saying
that a risk aversion therefore people
joining a big a big a poor that logic is
broken I tried to say that you know it
isn't it true you have a risk aversion
you should have participate in port but
you don't need to let it push too much
because you know if you could have a lot
of force but these guys just just just
you know put their hash rates in
different places and I truly believe the
cost of splitting my own hash power will
be much smaller than let these force too
much because all these you know the full
merger is much harder
okay thank you
[Applause]